[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
effectivement depuis plus de vingt ans
je travaille
j'explore les prix je lis décortique
sous tous les angles sous toutes les
coutures dans tous les secteurs
je les analyse je les comprends c'est
devenu mon métier mais au delà de mon
métier c'est aussi un péché mignon un
péché mignon en tant que consommateur
comme vous mais peut être est peut-être
aussi en tant que citoyen et c'est de
cela dont je voudrais vous parler
aujourd'hui vous faire part non pas de
mes certitudes je ne vais vous infliger
aucune vérité mais vous faire part d'un
certain nombre de doutes d'intuition de
tendance de risque qui pourrait arriver
demain
à vrai dire je pensais avoir tout vu en
matière de prix en 20 ans le prix d'un
médicament contre l'hépatite c est vendu
41000 euros ou bien le prix d'un billet
paris marseille en autocar à 5 euros
je pensais avoir fait toutes les
expériences d'ailleurs vous aussi vous
avez fait à votre manière à notre
manière une expérience d'explorateurs
quand vous êtes sur votre ordinateur
vous commander un billet sur internet un
billet d'avion et puis au moment de
réserver vous cliquez boom surprise le
prix a changé les frais de réservation
subitement augmenté cela vous énerve
cela vous agace vous dites mais
pardonnez moi l'expression tout cela
c'est du n'importe quoi c'est de la
loterie
et encore vous n'avez peut-être pas vécu
toutes les expériences je vous suggère
de faire la prochaine fois que vous
prenez l'avion
l'expérience suivante demandez à votre
voisin assis juste à côté de vous
combien il a payé le prix de son billet
vous risquez d'avoir une surprise bonne
ou mauvaise regardez ce slide
il s'agit d'une étude sur le prix des
billets de ryanair une étude
scientifique ça n'est pas une opinion ce
sont des milliers de vols de ryanair qui
ont été analysés et que voyez-vous sur
ce graphe dans un même avion
le prix oscille entre 20 et 180 euros
peut-être que quelqu'un dans l'avion à
payer 9 fois le prix du billet de son
voisin autre exemple vous sortez de
votre bureau pour faire les courses et
où détient cette fois ci je vais les
faire juste à côté je vais pas les faire
chez moi
mais dans la même enseigne et vous
apercevez arrivé à la caisse que
finalement le prix n'est peut-être pas
celui que vous payez dans le magasin de
votre quartier le prix 5% 10% plus cher
cela vous étonne troisième exemple vous
avez peut-être des enfants des étudiants
et vous leur avez offert pour qu'ils
puissent rentrer voir papa maman aller
chez des amis visiter la france un
abonnement illimité 76 euros par mois
pour prendre le train 76 euros c'est à
peine le prix d'un billet aller retour
paris marseille bref tout ça pour vous
dire quoi
le sentiment que vous avez que nous
avons c'est qu'il n'y a plus de prix que
c'est la grande loterie que les prix
marche sur la tête et vous en arrivez
même nous en arrivons même à douter la
défiance s'installe on nous on se dit
mais si les prix sont floues si les prix
sont fous c'est sans doute qu'il ya un
loup mais en réalité derrière cette
apparente loterie je voudrais vous
montrer qu'à une vraie logique
implacable une rationalité cacher et
pour la déchiffrer je vous propose avec
moi l'espace de quelques minutes je vous
rassure de chausser des lunettes froide
de l'économiste si vous chausser des
lunettes de l'économiste vous allez voir
un monde qui s'appuie sur un principe
éternelle le but
le rêve je dirais même le nirvana
employer les grands mots de toute
entreprise
c'est au fond de vendre le même produit
à des prix différents achats
le rêve ultime pardonnez moi
l'expression c'est le prix à la tête du
client
reprenons notre exemple de ryanair les
prix vous paraissent absurdes ils ne
sont pas absurde ils obéissent à une loi
parfaitement clair plus vous réservez
tard plus vous paierez cher ce qui est
normal vous êtes captifs pourquoi vous
faire un cadeau alors qu'il n'avait pas
le choix
d'autres choix que de voyager vous êtes
soit un homme d'affaires soit vous
voyagez pas nécessité puisque vous avez
réservé au dernier moment vous paierez
donc le prix cher la règle du jeu a au
moins un mérite elle est claire
transparente
plus tu réserves car plus tu payes elle
est ouverte à tous second exemple
pourquoi avez vous payé plus cher dans
le magasin juste à côté de votre bureau
qui est pourtant le même que celui de
votre domicile bas peut être que votre
bureau et dans un beau quartier où les
revenus sont en moyenne plus élevés
aucune raison de pratiquer des prix
unique
si les personnes qui habitent dans le
quartier sont plus riches dernier
exemple vous l'avez compris des
abonnements jeunes s'explique assez
simplement les jeunes ont peu de moyens
et surtout ils voyagent pour le plaisir
donc si je mets le prix normal
les jeunes ne voyageront plus ou alors
ils voyageront avec blaquart où les
autocars bref tout ça pour vous dire
quoi la discrimination c'est vieux comme
le monde
on n'a rien inventé mais vous êtes
d'accord avec moi la discrimination
jusqu'à aujourd'hui c'était assez facile
à comprendre
c'était assez simple votre âge jeune pas
jeunes éventuellement votre sexe
appelez-vous et boîtes de nuit
gratuit pour les filles ayant pour les
garçons la date de réservation plus vous
réservez tard plus vous payez cher et
puis votre lieu de résidence
pourquoi ses limites et la
discrimination parce que discriminer
discriminer ça n'a pas de connotation
morale discriminer ça signifie en
économie faire payer un prix différents
pour un même produit
c'est très long c'est très coûteux c'est
très compliqué pour un vendeur de savoir
qu'il en face de lui écrit sur votre
visage que vous êtes milliardaire ou
comme un riche qu'un milliardaire
ce n'est pas écrit sur votre visage que
vous adorez le chocolat au point que
vous êtes vous seriez prêt à payer 5
euros ou 6 euros
une tablette bref jusqu'à aujourd'hui la
discrimination c'est un peu restée la
discrimination a pas part mais tout cela
pourrait peut-être changer demain à je
n'ai pas de certitudes
je voudrais simplement partager avec
vous un certain nombre d'institutions et
de doute tout cela pourrait peut-être
changer de mains à cause ou grâce d'un
événement qu'on utilise tous tous les
jours d'une technologie internet et les
big data nous sommes peut-être demain à
deux doigts en tout cas les entreprises
sont peut-être à deux doigts de toucher
ce fameux nirvana consistant à faire
payer à chacun son prix pourquoi parce
que tous les jours nous serons sur
internet
nous allons sur les réseaux sociaux bref
nous laissons des petites traces des
petits cailloux
quand vous allez sur un site de
réservation vous dis parfois loguer vous
avec votre compte facebook
vous naviguez et lorsque vous naviguez
sur internet des coûts qui sont posés
sur vous des cookies ces petites puces
qui vont permettre de vous suivre vous
avez aimé un article on va vous demander
de le ur vous allez choisir de le leak
et révélant ainsi vos goûts vos
préférences vos tendances
bien entendu toutes ces informations
sont scrutés au non pas par l'oeil de
moscou par des milliers des millions
d'yeux ceux des annonceurs qui vont vous
classez vous triez faire des profils
femmes plus de 35 ans csp + habitants à
marseille et une fois qu'on vous à
profiler on va bien sûr vous ciblez un
produit existe déjà via une publicité ça
ça existe
et pourquoi pas demain du ciblage non
plus sur des produits mais en termes de
prix au fond pourquoi pas imaginer que
grâce à internet ou à cause d'internet
au fond demain chacun aurait son prix un
peu comme à la brocante
mais à la différence de la brocante
c'est une brocante en temps réel où tout
se joue en quelques millisecondes
or on dirait c'est sympathique votre
histoire mais c'est de la science
fiction c'est vrai c'est vrai que pour
l'instant il n'y a pas de preuve
empirique que les entreprises font des
prix à la tête du client sur internet
vous avez une enquête près sérieuse de
la cnil et de la répression des fraudes
qui vous dit mais finalement cette idée
qu'on a tous on a repéré mon adresse
internet
on va faire de l'ip et tracking et une
fois qu'on a on a repéré mon adresse
internet on peut savoir combien de temps
je me suis connecté
combien de fois j'ai tapé paris rome sur
internet et ainsi en déduire des
informations précieuses pour me faire un
prix spécifique et bien que nous dit ce
rapport tout cela reste pour l'instant
un fantasme mais le même rapport nous
dit que si vous réserver un billet
pendant les heures creuses
vous n'aurez pas tout à fait le même
prix que si vous le réserver aux autres
horaires il nous montre aussi que si
vous avez commencé par utiliser un
comparateur de prix avant de réserver
vous aurez également peut-être une
promotion et le sujet est pris tellement
au sérieux que le président obama dont
on peut supposer qu'elle a kind souci il
avait d'autres soucis que de
s'intéresser aux prix sur internet a
commandé un rapport
voyez ce rapport dont vous avez la
couverture big data encryption pricing
et que montre ce rapport il vous dit
technologiquement les prix personnalisés
c'est possible la question n'est pas de
savoir si l'on peut la question est de
savoir si les entreprises le veulent et
d'ailleurs le rapport illustre à l'aide
d'un exemple très intéressant l'exemple
d'un jouets vendus sur amazon vous avez
en abscisse deux années de ceux du prix
de vente de cet objet 2012 2014 et wake
le prix oscille entre 10 $ et 17 dollars
comme si les entreprises essayé de
tester les clients en fonction du prix
bref tout cela est de la science fiction
pour l'instant mais rien
technologiquement ne l'empêchent mais au
fond si cela venait à arriver
faudrait-il vraiment sont inquiétés oui
et non oui parce que si on a repéré que
vous êtes riche que vous êtes aisé à
cause de votre comportement sur facebook
de toutes les traces que vous avez
laissé alors on n'y a pas de raison de
vous faire des promotions vous paierez
le prix fort si je sais que vous aimez
tel produit il n'y a aucune raison que
je fasse une promotion après tout c'est
une idée vieille comme le monde
lorsque vous allez à la brocante et que
vous tournez pendant une heure autour du
vieux vélos solex de vos rêves
le vendeur vous a repéré il sera très
difficile ensuite de négocier une baisse
de prix dont premiers impacts de la
différenciation des prix ceux qui ont
les moyens
ceux qui vont révéler qu'ils sont
vraiment payeront plein pot plus
inquiétant encore quelles informations
ont été utilisées pour me proposer non
seulement un produit ciblé mais un prix
cible et mon âge j'ai l'habitude
mon sexe c'est déjà plus tendancieux je
n'y peux rien d'être un homme
ma religion mes préférences la sexualité
quelles informations ont été utilisées
pour me proposer ce prix ciblées alors
rassurons nous il ya des garde-fous
d'abord il ya les lois sur la protection
des données par personnel on ne fait pas
tout et n'importe quoi avec nos données
il ya peut-être un second garde fou
c'est la peur pas là notre peur la peur
des entreprises la peur des entreprises
de trop jouer avec les prix de telle
sorte que les clients à la fin vont se
dire mais on nous a pris un petit peu
pour des imbéciles et la sanction à
l'heure des réseaux sociaux peut aller
très vite
c'est ce qu'on appelle la e-réputation
mais soyons optimistes voyons si le
meilleur du big data et d'internet
premièrement et oui cela peut nous
étonner le gros avantage du big data
c'est que ça permet peut-être de faire
payer plus cher à ceux qui ont les
moyens
ça permet aussi de faire payer moins
cher à ceux qui n'ont pas d'argent si
vous êtes jeunes pauvres et qu'internet
vous à repérer vous aurez peut-être un
prix plus accès
cible que les autres et le rapport de
ban à le souligner leur apport pour à
mme obama insiste beaucoup sur ce point
en disant attention la discrimination
non pas au sens moral au sens économique
ça quand même une qualité
cela permet en ciblant les personnes à
faibles revenus de leur donner accès aux
marchés
et puis une seconde vertu une seconde
qualité du big data
c'est le ciblage des produits que nous
connaissons déjà vous avez tous fait
cette expérience vous lisez un article
du monde.fr de liberation.fr du
figaro.fr peu importe l'éditeur et puis
pendant la lecture vous recevez une
publicité sur les trottinettes
électriques
tiens c'est bizarre il ya deux jours
vous êtes allé sur un site vous
renseigner sur les trottinettes
électriques
c'est quand même pas mal vous avez reçu
enfin une publicité ciblée par rapport à
l'un de vos désirs
bref le big data ça n'est ni bon ni
mauvais cela apporte le meilleur y
compris parfois en termes de prix
concernant l'accès des plus pauvres aux
marchés mais aussi peut-être parfois le
pire
il faut simplement en avoir conscience
pour faire ses choix
faire ses choix peut-être pour jouer
avec la règle du jeu pour jouer avec
internet
vous savez que des astuces ou en tout
cas certains pensent avoir trouvé des
astuces pour déjouer les stratégies des
entreprises
vous avez deux économistes très sérieux
qui ont publié un papier dans économique
john hall
ils nous ont étudié des milliers de prix
de billets d'avion ils prétendent avoir
trouvé la règle je vous la donne il
faudrait réserver au 2 juillet huit
semaines avant le décollage et surtout
la réserver votre billet la nuit
pourquoi parce que la nuit les
secrétaires et des hommes d'affaires
dorment mais prendre conscience être
vigilant sur les avantages et les
inconvénients du big data
ça n'est pas tombé dans des solutions
trop simple trop simpliste trop
radicales et je voudrais terminer avec
une un événement d'actualité
il ya une directive qui est en cours de
discussion en europe qui interviendra
peut-être en 2018 qui vous permettrait
si elle était adoptée de bloquer tous
les cookies sur votre ordinateur en
clair quand vous connecter à internet
vous pourriez choisir de ne jamais être
suivis à la trace
on a envie d'applaudir des deux mains
c'est génial enfin tranquille plus de
publicités intempestives
ça n'est pas si simple ça n'est pas si
simple parce que aujourd'hui vous passé
plus de quatre heures par jour sur votre
smartphone et sur votre tablette
donc la publicité digitale c'est devenu
stratégique pas seulement pour les
éditeurs pour les sites gratuits
tiens faisons un petit raisonnement si
tout le monde bloque les cookies il ya
plus d'informations ciblées sur nous si
à moins d'informations ciblées sur nous
il ya moins de publicité ciblée donc la
valeur de la publicité diminue et les
sites gratuits ne peuvent plus se
financer
fini les recettes gratuite sur marmitons
fini la lecture des articles gratuits
sur le monde.fr on ira peut-être dans un
monde du tout payant
encore faut-il pouvoir payer vous voyez
je ne vais pas vous dire ce qu'il faut
faire
je souhaiterais simplement pour terminer
vous dire la question qu'on s'est posée
aujourd'hui celle de savoir que faire si
les prix personnalisés venait à se
développer sur internet
cette question là c'est une
responsabilité collective qui n'est pas
une question à laquelle un expert peut
répondre parce que ce n'est pas une
question d'économistes ce n'est pas une
question de consommateurs je crois que
c'est une question de citoyens merci
votre attention
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]